estos son los muchachos de batter que
murieron hoy la sangre Aún está fresca
de esta forma inicia el mensaje y
trigosin a los principales jefes de
defensa de Rusia el fundador de la
milicia paramilitar rusa los culpa de no
entregar municiones a Wagner causando
pérdidas importantes en sus tropas que
luchan en bacmut desde el inicio del
asalto a esta ciudad ucraniana tenemos
un 70% de escasez de municiones ministro
de defensa jefe del Estado Mayor general
hera Simón Dónde está la [__]
munición
horas después pregocín lanzó una
advertencia su milicia se retirará de
bacmut el día festivo de la victoria en
Rusia
y vamos a capturar totalmente backmud el
9 de mayo pero los burócratas
pseudomilitares detuvieron el suministro
de municiones para evitar que lo
hiciéramos ya pasaron a la historia como
cobardes desde
Moscú el kremlin se dio por notificado
del mensaje de Wagner pero no entró en
detalles según los servicios de
inteligencia de Reino Unido las
diferencias entre Wagner y el ejército
ruso comenzaron ante la supuesta
incompetencia de Rusia en la ofensiva
militar en Ucrania backmuth una
localidad de 70.000 habitantes antes de
la guerra ha adquirido una importancia
simbólica debido a la intensidad de los
combates entre tropas ucranianas y rusas
desde hace 9 meses a escasos kilómetros
de ciudades como danías y seperoniask
quien gane la batalla por bakmuth
también ganará líneas de suministro en
todo el frente este epicentro de la
guerra